each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay optimistically I assume the room is
now half full I'm really pleased to
introduce new blazer who completed his
PhD at ETH in Zurich fairly recently and
I had the pleasure to read his thesis
and thought i had to invite him over for
a talk as you can see he is going to
talk about a component language for
structured concurrent programming and i
don't know how honest he'll be about his
own achievement so one thing that I
found very impressive is where he built
the entire stack he designed a language
he implemented language he built the
runtime designed the runtime built a
significant application in that language
on top of that runtime and then they add
to performance benchmark it against if
you like commercially available
solutions I don't want to sort of take
much of your thunder away but that that
in combination left me quite impressed
so it's my great pleasure to introduce
look today and a handoff you many thanks
for the kind introduction so good
afternoon as I mentioned it will be
about the new programming language and
its implementation it's actually a
component oriented language for the
target or the aim of structured
concurrent programming so the motivation
behind this work is actually as far as I
believe the current state of the art
with its major manifestation of
object-oriented of the object-oriented
paradigm that dance however in my
opinion three let's say major problems
first of all the references are for me
it kind rather on structure concept that
this reminds me on on let's say the
go-to statements it's something that
allows you to arbitrarily interlink
object instances without having a
clearly specified resulting a clearly
clear specification of the resulting
shape of the object into the object
network that you gain at runtime in your
call gram and the result is it that if
you want to
hi Ricky's or something like
hierarchical encapsulation an object
that is to be composed of other object
instances of an structure without object
instances you can model that of course
but it's not guaranteed by the system
it's not guaranteed by the language so
you can accidentally construct the lingo
introduce a link that somehow falsifies
you intend to try Ricky and this is
naturally the consequence is that the
wrong time structure of an
object-oriented program as it is
perceived by the runtime system is
always a flat a flat graph a flat object
graph because every object instance
could be potentially linked to another
object instance as long as the types
match of course and therefore the
runtime season it has to go out to start
or two to be am be built with this with
this principle that that you have a flat
flat structure and if you want to model
hierarchies then this just the like the
sort of the program and it's not
something that is insured or guided by
the language and the runtime system the
second concept is the concept of
inheritance that is quite frequently
used is a figure if you observe it it's
a combination of two purposes the first
purpose is the purpose of type
polymorphism that we want to use this
concept to somehow have an object
instance and use it by multiple static
type some are some how to use the type
that is only like a subset of the
functionality of the eventual object and
the second purpose is the purpose of
implementation reuse that you use
inheritance to somehow reuse existing
functionality implemented in these super
classes the base classes and these are
two two purposes that often just fit
together but sometimes they also do not
fit together if you have the like a
square and the rectangle as a as a class
modeled as a class then you may model it
as the square in there in the
mathematical way you would say the
square is a special case of a rectangle
and nothing else and you will model the
square as a subclass of the
of the rectangle from the perspective of
the type polymorphism but from the other
way around you could also say that the
the square is something just a part of
the implementation of the rectangle and
this would then be default way to use
the inheritance just to do to make use
of the implementation to use and the
implementing in existing language also
shows a little bit this these limited
possibilities that it's either only
offered as a single inheritance
construct that you then if you have
multiple equivalent facets of an object
then you have to decide what which one
of them is like the major or the most
relevant bone to be modeled as the base
class and which should be modeled by
another concept interfaces for example
or you have a multi inheritance support
that has then it's a well-known problems
like this naming conflicts diamonds
columns are just some examples of that
and two third issue is is actually an
issue that is becoming increasingly
important in future I think that this D
rather pull support of concurrency
because concurrency is something that
has been nowadays whereas in similar
there the original object oriented
language that's been offered as a
primary language concept primary concept
of the paradigm it nowadays has become
that the object are mere passive object
and upon of them you use the the
threading mechanism especially
second-class concurrency mechanism that
then operates on these purely passive
objects and problem here is of course
that these threats because of the method
calls these threats can operate on let's
say on arbitrary passive object
instances we thought that is clearly
specified in your core gamers in the
language which what is the set of
potentially accessed objects of a threat
and therefore the result is that threads
may accidentally collide that they have
uncontrolled overlapping will dis often
called race conditions but also because
the flat due to the flat object graph
and also because of this the second
class setup of this reading mechanism
it's also
I did the deadlock there and ruin
starvation problems I inherently
promoted because the structure of the
potential overlapping and ways as threat
may operate through object dryer method
calls is not it's not clearly specified
and also methods are something a little
better a little bit unnatural in a
programming model where you have object
that have an interaction mechanism
because the methods are always blocking
and sometimes it's new it's not
understandable why because it's like if
you send somebody a message until then
you have to wait at the post box until
that the message has been received on
the other side somehow unnecessarily
like excluding concurrency in a primary
programming concept it's just some the
proceed to the notion that has been
institutionalized in the Indy currently
most prevalent object-oriented languages
so to say and so the approach has been
to create a new programming on a glog
aiming model that is from scratch newly
designed and just office like making a
tabula rasa and using and thinking about
concepts that would maybe better suit or
for these problems or to address these
problems and the language is only based
on a on a general object motion which is
called here component a component
content and the primary kind of the
primary characterization of a component
is that it is a general and abstraction
unit at the wrong time which encapsulate
both state and behaviors they do
something that is can be modeled for
example with variables and behaviors
what are the interactions between the
components and the kind of the principle
of object of these components is that
strict and capsulation is at the heart
of this language that all egg
dependencies which component asks have
to be openly specified and only by via
interface this is actually what can be
considered as it as the traditional or
the the
the consolidation of a component wants
it and if this language components can
therefore offer and require interfaces
the operator interface are kind of the
functionalities been represented outside
of our kind of a facet that is
perceivable outside a component it's the
functionality that is offered by the
component and the component males are
has to also specify its required
interface that I interfaces which also
buy all the components and the component
may requires or has need of it in order
to operate correctly or have sufficient
kind of primaries support to operate and
analogously do the class instance
concept components can be specified by a
template which then allows us to create
arbitrary and arbitrary number of
instances by it and here this template
for example illustrates there's a car
this may be perceived by two external
interfaces the vehicle interface for
driving and luggage base maybe there's
also some space in it that can help us
to do those on some article items in the
car and the required interfaces are
interfaced that the car may require in
order to to perform its usual usual
functionality and the component
instances need to be statically declared
in this language can be very simple like
car loan and car to being two instances
of this template car previously shown
and but however often this kind of
static fixing of the component template
is not not very kind of reasonable it is
often useful to not fix it and rather
postulate it in a polymorphic way by
only by only denoting or by only stating
the interfaces which are somehow to be
offered or may be required by component
for example here we have a vehicle
component that can be any component or a
component of any template as long as the
template has to offer a certain set of
interfaces so the component may offer
more than this vague and lack of space
interface would
still feasible within this declaration
but not less and on the other side the
component is actually the dual part the
component should not require more than
this then this required interface
because then it would have some kind of
hidden dependencies to its to its
environment so if the component would
put if it would be a car without the
radio system or navigation system based
on radio then the component would would
also be feasible it would only be a
radio if it's only would would only
regard the road interface and it is
language instead of only having a
concept of Eros the language of us a
generic collection of components here we
have a collection of cars of instances
of the car template that are to be
identified by an index that is here a
pair of the state name and the plate
number for example and this then allows
us within this collection to to allocate
or to use dynamic set of of components
the components have three relations
which which govern the structure the
first of all hierarchical composition a
component is able to very simply
consists of all the components consists
of a dynamic or static set of sub
components which are to be fully
encapsulated and only controlled by the
surrounding component instance and using
this mechanism of required and of the
interface is possible to connect the
interfaces connect interfaces of the
same name such that we can create a
network of component instances that are
however to be encapsulate and Ian
capsule again in a supper compared in a
super component and the third the third
mechanism is that these components have
their own kind of implementation and
only interact by way of a decoupled
mechanism disentangled mechanism of
sending and receiving messages a massive
communication mechanism and therefore it
is inherent that
own somehow run independently because
they just are not blocked while by
sending or not necessarily blocked by
lending and while interacting and
therefore there's an inherent mechanism
of off of concurrency because it is not
not prescribed that components have to
perform any kind of method calls for
example just due to outline how a
component may be implemented here it's
again the car component which has a set
of variables and their kind of an
internal behavior internal set up
sequence well the behavior he is
determined to set up sequence of the
component and the variables in this
language or something like contains four
variables or separate containers for
four variables here we have the variable
anjanette is able to store one component
of the template big in a capital engine
and here we have a collection of wheels
which may here be a static number and
then the setup script for example can
ask then allowed to to create for
example component instances and connect
the interface here for example we have
the engine component that has required
interface keys and this interface is
then by this statement connected to the
Opera the interface keys of the gearbox
one and the same is applied for for
example the wheels that are judging this
kind of illustrative example for example
connected to the gearbox and in this
language will be also possible to
connect let's say outer interfaces that
this up at the super component connects
the ultra interfaces to the intercom
interfaces and also required interface
may be kind of forward an ultimate yeah
please only made at the time when you ng
later kenichi she can also change that's
what actually next slide or the next
line that should show up so here it is
by this way of example it's just
something that can be perceived as sore
as static so a stamping set up of a car
component but the be kind of the
transition to a dynamic sinner is is
just right in the same way for example
here we have a traffic simulation that
has the crates for example a dynamic
number of cars so a number that is for
example attorney by an external XML file
for example or something that maybe be
on the liar and inaudible Devils the
space of locations within this
simulation setup and it's actually the
same way it does not matter whether it
is a kind of health is more dynamic
dynamic characteristics or static here
we create the road and a new center
instance and then repetitively for
example just here we create cause until
we all its decide that down and off
cancer yes please you operator you have
there in terms of in if a component is
identified only by the I interfaces that
it requires and supplies and then how do
you specify what is required in order to
create a new museum oh yeah yeah Frank
some hits the very simple as you already
seen it's the very simple instantiation
operator that just creates a new
instance of of this template type within
these variables but however if we if I
allowed to scroll back a little bit if
we have something like this polymorphic
declaration then with the new statement
a second parameter we specify the
specific template of which the component
should be created so this would mean
here if we just specify roti something
that offers the road into the road
network is something that offers the
road interface and we have here like an
any and Annie a nanny construct then we
say new road road network a second a
second prompt yes
this new road isn't producing messages
before these other things are connected
in no that's what I should come later
but i can already just briefly mention
it the components are only able to
interact by message communications
whenever their interface is connected as
long as the interface is not connected
the messages of just blocked with regard
to this interface so if the car for
example it's a little bit all natural
sends messages to devote then and the
Lord is not yet connected during the
sector or doing the previous enter then
just imagine messages are cute until d
all the messages up to a certain level
of the buffer are cute because it's kind
of of transparent way and whether the
message sending is as its non blocking
or blocking because it just shouldn't
matter for the time perceiving of of a
single component yes yes this is also
possible it's possible in these
negatives to disconnect but then I will
come later to that the the components we
will exchange messages according to a
protocol and then the protocol has to be
be completely Oh for allowing like a
shape to another another connect so a
little bit here it's it's this way of
interface connection look similar to
references but it has some subtle
differences that is that the reference
the interface connections are always
connections to be set by the surrounding
component so that the there is a
hierarchical control upon creating the
the interface connections where's for
references it is just something like a
value in an object-oriented negative can
be copied around and therefore allows to
to somehow create arbitrary structures
and therefore because there is no
limitation or no no kind of guarantee
for an intended hierarchy then the
system has this flat this flat object
graph in the end antique of all until
these interface connections or dual
connectors between incoming and outgoing
connection points such in contrast to
the to the references which are
something like an a symmetric link that
directly leads to note
without that the object is is maybe kind
of of willing to to accept such a
reference this point of reference and
this at the end then leads to a long
time start to a long time talk to that
as I would say is more general than
adjust the flat object graph that is
namely a hierarchy of Cibola networks so
every component is able to again contain
a network of arbitrary shape of sub
component in this language and ever we
have have a hierarchy in this in this
programming model and this then also
allows us to do a little bit rethink the
existence of an object or component
where as an object orientation it's just
say that with garbage collected systems
the object we have controlled for
creation but not for deletion and the
existence just lies in this postulation
that whenever it's not reachable anymore
from a chain of strong point is from a
root then it's a not identify any more
and assessment therefore can be removed
but this is not the perfect mechanism of
of collecting object because an object
may be kept referenced by it by
accidentally kept reachable and
nevertheless would be never used again
and here in this language we have
something like hierarchical lifetime so
if we delete the component it's obvious
that the sub components are no longer be
directly accessible from other than
therefore we can immediately delete
these some components as well so we gain
regain possibility of culture of
exploiting the hierarchy for for the
also DD allocation mechanism and here
it's also possible to to explicitly
where delete the component that we say
oh this is no time we delete this
component and then the interfaces are
disconnected because of this duel
mechanism and then the component will be
removed with its top convulse and
definitely this language we have
something like a memory management
mechanism without needing a garbage
collector and we don't do not have any
low level dangling pointers as pointers
which which immediately lead to memory
that is that is no longer allocated we
can have something like a component that
has a disconnected interface but this is
safe
managed in the language and the messages
will be blocked but it's not something
like just just mirror address is leading
to an unallocated space and the
mechanism of concurrency or interaction
is that as already mentioned d
components have their own lifetime
scenario and therefore this lifetime
scenario and will interact by message
communication deputy components are can
become currently executed so it's it so
it's remains on the decision of the
random system which degree of
concurrency can be or should be
exploited and therefore from the
perspective of the programming language
every every component as it as its
internal logic that runs concurrently
and only interact by exchanging messages
and here for example if we consider this
example then the component which offers
the interface can be considered with
regard to this interface as a server off
of this of this interface because it
offers it of this communication and the
cars are something like clients because
we require this interface and in this
language also it is free or in build an
inbuilt mechanism of using separate
communication channels so to say with
every client individually and this is a
real illustrated later as i mentioned
does this with this date full
communication but the components cannot
arbitrary send messages and receive
messages as they like but they have to
feel fearful theta kind of a formal
formal protocol or communication
protocol that needs to be specified
within the interface and this protocol
is using a notation that is also known
as simulated or this is actually II BNF
that's next time this bankers now a
formalism that is in my opinion is best
finding in a very compact then and still
readable form this protocol here for
example we have a message request news
that is an incoming message from the
perspective of the server component so
the car component has to somehow
delivered via the radio interface
notification that this interested in
receiving some kind of
for example traffic information and then
denoted by these square brackets this
denotes a repetition of zero or
arbitrary many times that this sub
expression of e BNF will be executed or
will be needed to be executed in this
yes the restaurant across half the side
effects any other side effects will get
possible if any method I'll be sending a
message other side effects are possible
in the system except that it can be
received or should be received on the
other side not before this fella from
the purse back a perspective of the
singles and the component open so then
this this under like this software so in
this example then the traffic center
components with will respond with with a
few messages that they are either a
jammed that it denotes that there is a
jam totaling a newly trampling or
previously congested road that it has
been that has cleared in meantime and
this continues as long as the the server
component does not send this end of news
message and then this this communication
is or this protocol of this interaction
stateful interaction is permanent just
to sketch the the implementation of such
a protocol we have the declined just
performing maybe within its its internal
lifetimes internal implementation
performing this this send and receive
statement using the GSB like notation
here we have a receive statement and
annexing tactical expression that is
just received test so it's a little bit
in the same written in the same way but
here it is really a syntactical
statement it is language really
differentiate between distinguish
between statement and expression here
this is if something is just an
expression this is a statement at camp
can't be mixed up on like unlike the C
language for example and here we just
test is there the next arriving message
of the type Jan if yes then we accept
the receive this message
when this fruit I within this
implementation and the traffic sentient
component is the component which offers
the interface and therefore deserves and
in this example should be able to
maintain a stateful communication with
Annie with any client separately and
therefore we have here such an
implementation block that implements the
offered interface and for every client a
separate instance of this implementation
block is incarnated and then runs as a
syntactical let's say a service process
within the the traffic's and the
component for just performing the the
server-side communication with the
individual client and as we already see
between components there are there's no
kind of synchronous kind of a jam
synchronous execution transfer so it the
process is just run within a single
component but however in case of
soldiers server component we have
multiple such internal internal process
because we have multiple client services
and therefore because the communication
protocol is inherently kind of
synchronized because the send and
receive is the disentangle interaction
we only have to concentrate in this
language on explicit synchronization
within within a component so in this
language we have the possibility of
using monitors like usual monito
synchronization within a component then
we can state explicit and share the
exclusion directives and also use
something like an array a great
statement that waits on the fulfillment
of a boolean condition and therefore the
become it's very simple for the compiler
to only perform an intra component
analysis to determine whether let's say
D the accesses on shared component
variables for example are sufficiently
protected by exclusive or shared locks
such that this very low level race
conditions I excluded it is and it's
lame
just to summarize view maybe extra
features of the languages already
mentioned this encapsulation where it's
also allowed to get a component that the
surrounding component can forward in
coming out exterior interfaces to two
inner components directly linked them
and it's also possible that their
component can require more than one
interface of the same name so if there
is a kind of a of a hotel then we may
have multiple phone lines for example
this is also possible and within their
the messages are able to have parameters
that may be simple data values but can
be also component so that we can we are
able to somehow detach a component it
like a disconnect its interfaces if they
are called connected and then cheap so
to say a component within a message as a
parameter to in order to another
component and this yes when you when you
receive this component one memory starts
running because if they don't have their
own thread right if they're actually win
start running when it's created so you
have to already have it PL ok but if its
interfaces are not connected then you
won't receive it outside the component
and therefore you can somehow shape
rounding components let's say a running
engine for example I bought the engine
both to have any side effect if its
interfaces are not connected so if you
create an engine and there's some
internal logic let's say a setup script
that has no external effect then this
can happen but as soon as the engine
wants to somehow connect with the
gearbox order to perform force on the
gearbox and this won't have any effect
until it is for example received at the
car in the car too and connected with
its surrounding and then can perform for
example Falls is represent possible if
you get race conditions due to
a component this fred is running this
producing event but then you're also
connecting to as interface and now it
would matter whether you connected to
the interface before it produced an
event now this is actually happier but
this is an important question when you
create the wrong time system for it then
you have to do a dress up
synchronizations due to the mapping 2d
to a simple machine but from the
perspective of the programming language
the messages are just in this in this
buffer blocked until it is connected but
when connecting the runtime system takes
care of this of this fine granular
synchronization that the messages are
then as soon as it is connected properly
forwarded and nothing is lost or nothing
getting start going in the face the
lower stone is connected can you start
seeing messages on them
so you have a pair of partially
connected back this is this will be
possibly matter I mean independent of
the runtime yeah which order you know is
it's actually a component shot should
not perform hear something like multiple
ways of if you have multiples ending you
can can perform multiple sending in kind
of a sequential order but not in this
multiple parallel order so otherwise it
would matter if you have like a
component able to send in wrong time a
message of channel a and then impaired
that a message over B and then only one
would what would be recent but if the
component is just executing like a
sequential protocol of of the domain
process of the main transmissions and
then it's it's natural if there is one
only one interface connect then this can
go on but then with regard to the second
interface the connection won't continue
the fight over your such as an example
if you're implementing lawyer do you
have spoken at acknowledge that you have
wielded connected or propeller and
connected and patient logic after that
also is it to see whether we are
connected yet I don't also I have not
offered this in the language because I
thought it should remain transparent
this this environment I but I'm not sure
whether this is could be because if you
have as soon as you have something like
can I send this this way of expression
then you come into these problems that
you don't know on which interface should
I send and so maybe it's really the
assumption is that the component is
fully connected in order to operate and
and but the ice but it's a good question
there is with regard to such multiple
interface days this is recommended you
might give my motor neuron where you
have a dying block for problem yeah
were we oh yeah yeah I'll even say that
it is solving any concurrency problem
deadlox can still be designed with that
duque de cycle and then then construct
the protocol way run into such cyclic
decision problems and then count count
continually long and then also as
already mentioned with the interface
polymorphism we have something like
multi inheritance in a lightweight form
that we can only use it for polymorphism
and do not have to to only use one one
of those and fibia mobile that has a
road vehicle and motor vehicle interface
and both are equivalent you can't say
the one is more important than the other
than you can just just simply model that
like that dislike that and the dapoli
morphism like this purpose this first
purpose of polymorphism is clearly
separated as a concept from the
mechanism of reuse that is here in this
language I've intended this that this
should be enabled by using components
and connecting it to the environment and
the the language is also for kind of
interoperability purposes there's this
clear separation between interfaces and
the implementation that is at the the
principle of the language and effort
would be conceptually also possible to
implement terminal components so to say
components that are not again containing
something wants to be implemented in any
other language this is a click for for
building this bridge with all the system
there were with all the languages and
it's also used with regard to the
implementation that the colonel is
implemented such a component and
business implemented in a more low-level
language that map's batter to the to the
underlying machine I'm sure so we are
directly for we are here with wrong time
station so this still languages
implements not only a like a father
thinking thinking activities also
implemented with the small kernel
operating system is exaggerated it's
something like a small kernel that is
that's directly executing all the beer
machine
without underlying operating system
except the load and it's a designed of
course to efficiently execute this
language with that which has some
substantial differences with regard to
the resource requirements to classic
language because every component needs
to be or should be in the programming
model become currently executed you have
a completely different requirement for
your system whereas classical systems
are somehow optimized for efficient
sequential or procedural execution this
system should be able to execute the
large number of processes not large
number of this internal or parallel
component and therefore the system
offers the concept of lightweight
process that has dynamic micro stack i
will go to detail in the next slide and
also the context switches between these
process and have to be particularly
optimized and i just mentioned this fear
the system also has inbuilt
synchronization mechanisms like this
communication protocol is dynamically
check then and implement by such a
buffer that is that is behind the scenes
and also monito synchronization is
already in build in the system and
memory management does of have already
mentioned this with the hierarchical
memory management can be simplified also
here it's no virtual memory needed
bigger memory management need because
all these components can run in the same
address space and therefore decision
does not have any virtual memory
management we see we'll see later that
also the virtual memory management will
not help for the implementation for
example of the stack management of
process just to very briefly say these
processes so every grossest like every
thread it can be compared to a threat in
the usual terminology in operating
system every threat that has its
execution context that is thought in a
stack and in this system this process
are able to have an arbitrarily small
stack that can be it does the size can
be even smaller than page
molarity so it can be only like a few
home the diets or few bites and this is
able therefore it's no longer based on
this virtual memory mechanism boo
because we have to get small than that
and the stack is also with regard to
extensions at runtime it's it's no
longer represent as a contiguous
pre-allocated virtual memory space that
is than just a talk the the real pages
or real frames being allocated but it's
a implemented as a stack that can grow
at runtime I'll shrink again by
representing it as as a sum to say as a
linked list of blocks so it's the
separation between stack space and heap
space also no longer so so it's no not
in the system anymore here this deck is
something that is allocated on the heap
and for the components as we have
already seen there are no method called
but what communication interaction
therefore this is not not an arbitrary
deep as long as there are no procedures
used within a component there is no des
no political and effort is very simple
for the compiler to pre-compute the the
actual size of the actual context the
execution context the component needs to
execute its internal process and
therefore the stack size can be can be
better precomputed and therefore
pre-allocate such the download or in
often no usually no wrong time
extensions or reductions of the stack
needed yes sighs remember of our station
in the alligator component
the minimum yet this could be for
example I think eight byte are
sufficient because you need a pointer to
the component but the closest need to
point to the component and maybe hope I
don't know it depends on how many
variables and how many space you need to
execute its internal internal logic if
you have something like complex logic
and need to have temporaries like
temporary evaluation of expressions and
so then you need more and we will come
also later to this also for context
switches we need some some space of
course so just very this is more
technical very briefly this can be this
is implement here if a positive the
component would have internal procedure
codes that wouldn't be visible outside
then this can be is here down in the
system by that the compiler inserts for
procedure called end and procedure
returns extra code that then performs
the allocation of extra blocks and then
shifts this deck point to do it and then
then yeah I parses the parameters into
them and the an often scenario is that
the component can be interrupted or can
be can be at any time there can be
occurred and interrupt and the interrupt
of course needs some space and and it's
it's not reasonable to pre-allocate this
space on the component stack but for
this interrupts and also for system
freaking systems called system calls
they are executed on a processor stack
on a system stack so every process in
this system is that against the system
should have a static number of processes
has a pre-allocated system stack of
sufficient size that is just there to
execute this internal procedure calls
and and they have to fulfill this
principle of run to completion so they
have to be fully executed until the
execution can order the corresponding
processor can continue it's an execution
with the ordinary processes
and the contacts which is also very
simple in this system they are behind
the scenes default be synchronous
context switches these are those which
are for example happens when a component
weight soil condition or a message or
receiving message for example then this
disk can be implemented by an ordinary
procedure called the system call behind
the procedural system called and the
programming language should is memory so
it's designed to be a memory safe and
therefore in decision there is no
restrict principle of separating the
colonel and the user space is not
involved here because it's really
assumed that the programming language
should not somehow override the system
memory and therefore it can be dis dis
chief to the kernel mode to do switch
the candle leather threading so to say
is not not not here implement or not not
needed here and therefore these these
addresses so as a geosynchronous chief
can be also such as in cronies contexts
which can be very efficiently execute
gears just illustrative how simple this
can be by by exploiting somehow the
procedure prologue and epilogue just for
performing the backdrop of the of the
corresponding synchronous state so the
Brecon say a little bit more about that
so the procedure prologue will usually
store all all let's say variables that
are still in temporary use on the snack
and then we'll also store the
instruction point at the old frame point
and by just shifting the frame pointer
we shift to another of the stack and
this neck is in the same kind of the
same format it's also back up in the
same format and then by the procedure if
you look this state can be restored but
on them on a different second and this
continued again this is not my invention
disease just just to show how simple
this can be for example implement and
the preemption is is a little bit more
let's say advanced or experimental basis
and the azan thoroughness
context switch that is in this system no
longer only performed by the hardware by
the time a regular but somehow supported
by software by the software and did the
idea the goal is that a process does not
need over like overly space for storing
all registers on online asynchronous
which because just this bankrupt this
extra backup space will be low already
of substantial amount per process to
store all all the registers for dynamics
and SSD to these edges of not in used at
the point of air of an interruption and
ever it's not very reasonable in this
system or very Mike call stacks to to
perform a full backup on every every
preemption until it's done with some
let's say some preemption check it's
still called preemption but with some
checks that are inserted in the code
such that these checks are executed in
guaranteed small time steps and
therefore it is obvious that for every
loop we need such a preemption checking
for every kind of procedural invocation
as we can have recursive invocations for
example we need such a such a check and
also for sequences exceeding a certain
maximum time a maximum first time we
need such as checks and these checks
show us just there to in in sufficiently
small steps checks check whether certain
time interval x lives of the process has
expired and if so the district's
immediately performed this kind of
synchronized preemption and the purpose
is already has mentioned to only store
what is necessary because the compiler
and this happens only behind the scenes
so the program does not see anything of
this this is just something that is
compiled by the compiler into the
machine code and this trans man to the
program and this only there and the
compiler then knows which veggies design
use and by just putting these checks
that reasonable places may be mostly be
higher between statements it is actually
nothing to be all nearly nothing to be
to be safe and therefore and this is
what's my
original intention is to not have any
separate pre-allocated backup space just
to have a full set a dreadful backup set
for purchased and two checks are very
simple as the process the pipeline is
mostly under kind of on the used if
memory access and perform such that with
regard to my example which I use them to
which I will come late it's really a
very nearly not remarkable gone time
overhead just to perform this chance
just here this is a kind of a benchmark
that is not so let's say not so relevant
because it's just the benchmark with
with toy examples that are just showing
a little bit giving a flavour of the
system that is optimized to with regard
to to concurrency but not let's say two
sequential programming and therefore the
focus is he also on on processes and
concurrency this as already mentioned
the system is able to execute a very
high number of processes here is a very
simple an example of houses that consume
and produce we need resources as a small
toy simulation and it's here observable
that this system that the amount of
processes that their support by the
system depends naturally on the real
memory space that it's offered because
this determines how many snacks and
process can be allocated but it's also
that it depends on the complexity of the
components if the cabal's require most
based on certainly the number will go
will decrease and ordinary systems have
of course this problem that this tax
have this conservatively pre-allocated
virtual space and will run out of
virtual space virtual memory space this
is a little bit yeah it's a interesting
to see that not the real memory spaces
becoming scales with the virtual memory
space urgency because then the address
space just to perform this contiguous
growing of the stack will then be will
then be the limiting number and it's
also with in the in the existing system
it's difficult to say with a threat
needs hundred kilobyte or 30 kilowatts
always either too
all or too big so it's either running
out of the stack or being too evasive
virtually yes before them is just 32
yeah because 64 this is actually this is
cool then this virtual memory space will
not be of any matter anymore because
then we have so much more space this is
true but still there is this these
needles also having the not only the
virtual space for for performing the
stackoverflow check or a locker but also
the real memories of govern because then
we need for for example 4 kilobyte real
manually per stack because we have to do
allocate in page granularity and this is
also would already be a problem that we
would spoil this this goal and also and
this is also a little bit subjective so
to say this is naturally into L like
concurrent programs that are really
relying on frequent interactions others
are substantially more efficiently
because this is just this context
switches which are particularly
optimized here if we have something like
a mountain goat problem then this is not
so fast because the sequential execution
is not so optimizing compiler is a
rather simple one man compile and and
it's here really concentrated on fine
granular frequently interacting
concurrency and you will see just now
why this is necessary here the goal was
it not this language has been
intentionally designed for this kind of
broader abstract goals of improving this
or giving a different view at the
object-oriented programming model and
but it's also kind of validated by and
by a practical substantially practical
example that is a traffic simulation and
the idea was because object orientation
was invented for simulation so it's
somehow obviously also use simulation as
a kind of a test case it's a good test
case to evaluate kind of a new object
oriented language and here by the table
Berlin they have such a department or
such a research institute that which
performs seemed
relations they have actually I have
supported them in building a new traffic
simulation that has somehow two goals so
the goals of this project at two namely
to somehow evaluate what is the benefit
of modeling with regard to the
simulation that was the primary goal and
the second goal is the more similar the
more technical goal is there a
possibility of having a faster
simulation due to this maybe new
modeling and maybe also in comparison to
this database system that are somehow by
advanced not not designed for this
purpose and this language obviously
somehow supports this more initial
thinking of similar really modeling
components or objects also as active
instances where as in classical traffic
simulation as they did that the cars
were modeled as passive objects that
were somehow moved by a central
schedulers Health Program scheduled at
from time steps then moves the car for
example across junctions and so on this
is this discrete event simulation by a
single cell program schedule schedule
that that performs this these movements
here the cars are somehow modeled with
the self closed internal behavior so the
cars are somehow performing their own
movements and their own way things on
traffic jams and performing also their
individual planning here so this is
things that count can be modeled before
but they are somehow improve by the
programming model because this is the
principle of this model that components
can have an activity and benefits were
here that this caused the simpler
implement because this explicit saddle
is kind of we can get rid of that also
this dissuading use that are of needed
so waiting that the shed scheduler has
to park the car the passive cars into a
waiting truck take either gone out again
can then be some are is in this new
simulation down behind the scenes in the
long-term season which has been the shed
is the scheduling of the concurrent
threads and this is naturally this is in
this is more optimized then
and just using the self mobile data
structures and the virtual time there's
also this car art or not wrong just by
randomly by the by the speed of the
program but by the computer the
scheduling system schedule but wrong by
a kind of virtual time axis so in the
languages or something like that cars
can wait for certain virtual time just
at the speed of the concurrency called
like complies with the real observed
speeding our natural world because it's
not the speed of the system schedule
that determines the quality of the
simulation and therefore here the
simulation is is certainly faster than
the net based just the the same like the
analog is implementation by using
instead of active component costs using
a car with a tract disease of course
something that is that is somehow
abusing the threat the threat notion but
also with regard is sequential that this
was by table in the sequential c++
implementation because this has a
completely different simulation model
did the classical model is something
with an explicit scheduler moving over
the time axis and moving because because
a discrete event simulation this is a
kind of a discrete event simulation
which does not perform bigger time steps
because this would be too expensive to
always calculate the inning on time
scale and dissimulation is performed
with them with the resolution of one
second so really big simulations are
here performed this is an emulation of
of the zurich of the zurich traffic with
stata used from home the government and
then the simulation is also faster the
classical model but this is just kind of
using a different algorithm so to save
for performing the simulation just to
briefly conclude before I will show yes
you be able to refer anything about the
scale of the odeon
orders of magnitude difference in the
two rows for your system versus the
sequence possible here it is you now
this is here because that the system
runs over this time axes and theater
dance just over the necessary effects
it's not so meaningful it's just
comparing to what they had before and
this is optimized to very large
simulation not to two very small
simulation and here it's just kind of a
comparisons with two different system
worlds and so it's very difficult to say
it's just showing be here in where the
several years having sex yeah so there's
some kind of a yeah yes that's true that
is because the complexity of
interactions between the cars are not
linearly growing because this car decay
they get into jam if you have just
thousand cars and this just wants to and
if you have 260,000 files just driving
by the central point in Zurich then you
have a problem then this can go on and
go on and go on yes the question for
parking fee increase is very small yeah
this is cool because this simulation is
implemented this way that this goes over
the time axis and if the simulation is
kind of on drew on the d2l or if there
are only few cars and this just runs
kind of in idle so to say but there's
also for bigger simulations then we also
i did not find any kind of because they
could think here that this is growing in
in a different like in a less let's
tremendous scale up but this is also a
problem because if we have more than
these cars than this simulation is so
over like over jammed or over congested
that there's no that would no car would
arrive in the end it at the final
destination so it's really here it's
something like the the maximum export a
or the maximum capacity of this is erick
net but it's difficult to say it if you
do something like
like a practical or kind of practical
measurements then it's difficult to
compare them because then you have have
just the goal of the practical result if
I am permitted I will just briefly ass
mention some conclusion so this language
has been designed for some conceptual
advantages for hierarchically controlled
structure so this is with regard to the
wrong time structures that have some
kind of guarantee hierarchy in build and
also the concurrency is kind of a
primary language from that concept that
in my opinion is more structured because
it's on how contained within a component
and blow no longer being spread out
among different components and the
technical advantage see that this
decision d which is particularly
optimized despairs simple system
optimized with regard to scalability and
alpha of parallel process and also the
performance for frequently interacting
concurrent processes is particularly
optimized and due to the the programming
model no garbage collect listen this was
also something to see whether there is a
different way of having a different
memory management that is not less I
would say less lucid then then having a
government and the practical
applicability was the goal of this this
case study with table in that shows that
that it's on a new languages as as
victim sometimes it it's like not only
learning a new vocabulary word
vocabulary but also a new world of
thought and it's somehow if the language
influences your way of modeling
something or solving a problem this is
then different them than just using a
passive model and then scheduling the
cars by let's say a central authority
that has like puppets moves all cars
around and they also like this the
smaller examples which show with regard
to the to the concurrency speedo and at
the end I thought I will shortly
demonstrate decision so the system is is
a
land is not so pompous that the to the
desk not there is some graphical output
will not tremendous it's really kept to
a minimum and for this purpose I will
have to restart the system they will do
a cold wisdom because this goes for most
of them and first I will not start into
my runtime system between the oberlin
season because mine is really only the
wrong time season and not the
development system so it is also here a
little bit differently how do you say
just because there's no editor in my
system this is ordinary oberlin season
is something that has been developed at
the eth by different group net and here
I've just kind of Michael Graham text so
for example I can show here a simulation
that is actually a produce to consume
sorry I will concentrate on my screen
because it's somehow unnatural to just
to show a few more examples written in
this component language we here have
something like a producer consumer
example that is a simulation containing
other templates it's also a nesting of
the static templates that is not the
hierarchical structure drum plan and
here we have a producer that somehow is
ending just said number of messages a
consumed is very stupid example actually
this compute this just receives this the
other component receives these messages
they are the interfaces saying that the
one side is just standing and the other
is just the other interface just for the
purpose of receiving messages and
there's a bounded buffer implemented
with monitors incra nization where we
have some like an exclusive monitor lock
we're waiting that the certain
capacities there does it kind of a
self-created restriction and and here we
have the data output that just wait
whether there is something to deliver
and when it's not finished and then we
do let's say DD hierarchical setup that
we built
above a consumer produce and connect the
interface and then we get something like
that that's the very simple example and
then we have also something like a sieve
of eratosthenes it's maybe a little bit
too much to go through it there we have
it number generator that offers a number
scream we have as if that has an office
and on this treatment requires form and
so on and then we build the this
pipeline of it's actually like a design
pattern the Arabs eve of Eratosthenes is
the design pattern of the pipeline of a
concurrency partner Levinson and then
also a token earring example is here
good to show a high number of this very
limit the system this is only with 250
megabytes so it's really an absolute
asian system to compute the scientist
but we can can let that run to see that
the system with this very limited main
memory of 200 kilo began on so many
nodes 200,000 parallel parallel close
asses in a token ring set up where we
have these notes created and then the
neighbors created with this mode
operator to the symmetric neighbor and
so on there's this traffic simulation
that actually consists of a plenty of
modules they said there's a XML leader
and evidence what's here in this low but
I can't go through it but just me just
shortly open this this is the main
simulation with the cars offering a set
of interfaces here performing hits
waiting for this virtual time for
example and pieces but I don't have the
time to go through that just want to
show that there is the source code and
for the simulation we have a certain
certain set of input data delivered by
these Swiss where the Swiss governments
which have the statistics of also having
the Zurich network and also data of
persons doing a certain having a certain
plan in mind to go for their work and
where they planned to drive through and
these are a lot of of plans and I've
just for here I have computed the
simulation with
ten thousand or something ten thousand
cars just at four thought you had to be
able to do that within this time and now
I shift from the development system to
my to my mini current this is just hear
this varies oh yes coming so it's very
simple it's a very simple interface so
at the top desti where you rewrite your
commands and imperil you can get output
here this can be can be textual or even
graphical output they will now run first
is this simulation which was this
producer-consumer exempt they won't
happen much just that these components
are created the exchanging like here a
million of message via this bond the
buffets now look I be finished and then
we can say like show resource now we
have five components in this system and
all courses already completed here and
we see we have exactly 250 megabytes
remember it's also on top you see won't
process it's very very old machine and
then we are able to for example delete
this component meet with name x and then
we have again only one component and the
whole memory back except decode the code
memories cash T we can also run this
token ring example it should have more
more resources here we see it's building
this network and then we now have
200,000 process and then this of course
need some memory and then it's it's
already finished
and dissimulation i have i've let them
run before but i have something like an
animator that shows you it's also not so
graphically impressive but we should
show now the result of such a
computation with the road animated at
hand advice on some code some component
code and then connect this this new road
animator component photos of the
simulation we disc requires the file
system and the file system is new
interface that is offered by the system
component itself that's the kernel
itself it also requires receiver in
parallel it's starting to read in this
xml file via also such a parallel read
and it has required some system time for
performing dee dee simulation build all
the the graphical output simulation and
there's also graphically you needed it
so that are all interfaces required by
this program so to say Sokka grams are
also components then we see here hit
this zoom of this Zurich of the Zurich
area where you can adjust you can figure
out his I think the central is this
Zurich lake is I think a bridge to what
is it robs feel I'm with you oh it's
more like and you see here the cars have
distant are only ten thousand cars are
here displayed with such a rat dots and
we see here at the time missus simulator
but the simulation is actually and this
is not impressive it's just for
calculating the simulation it's not for
viewing doing is just fall for show
purposes so to say it's just the
simulation rounds computes this data and
then we will deliver them again in a
file that can then be used for example
ladies a baleen do is busy here they are
this visa really early birds on
something it's not they were quite early
I'd ever see we have a lot of traffic
here already for this view you know move
and I think that's at least what i have
i have prepared and yeah so thank you
for your hash
so I was going to ask have you tried
simulating your language and wrong time
it sounds like me it looks like you just
started from scratch try stimulating
this on existing system yes bezel I've
shown before this this one C++
simulation is the official so to say
implementation of meaning your runtime I
no no it's unfortunately so to somehow
have an emulator that Browns my no no
unfortunately no but this I would wonder
whether it can be executed because it's
like a kernel it really start there's no
linux or something underneath it could
be executed I hope so in a in a virtual
machine because otherwise the
implementation of the virtual machine
would be right unless i have used some
kind of hidden norm specified
functionality which shouldn't be the
case in this case of the process during
the graphic utilization that are sort of
go really slow
are right mmm but that's still love the
actual simulation no this is invisible I
can I could stop this year but this
requires some more time because this
this plan fights are really excessive
and I need to be passed this would be
they can start it but it's the problem
we run out of space service the
simulation produces data without ever be
installed if you like the graphic system
is consuming that later you cannot
follow run out of the specimen yes maybe
yes yeah it's it's like that that this
this simulation of this graphics is kind
of just using existing calculation
results but the calculating yeah this is
just non graphical than this just dumps
down this data into a fine but this is
truly this desire not yet modeled as a
as a pipeline of of capone's but then
they will slow down certainly because
the graphics is here not optimized is
just very simple visa more than nothing
particularly Optimus also the devices
and that's the reason why it took a
little bit longer to start this output
because these external files need to be
read and it's actually devices or the
disk access is not it's very simple with
this with piyo mode and not with data
are like a college no no this this
postmaster and goes mastering support
but this is just questions of extending
the cure it's literally the kernel with
some let's say extensions to see
something and also this form this has
designed and so it's nothing nothing
particular with regard to that that's
really the focus was on this invisible
so to say system system building
I don't know yam no no I mean in
Switzerland like I have a small company
but I'm open for any kind of its with a
company of of of industrial business
like a software engineering and software
design provider but I am open for any
kind of disk elated and wondering like
you build up a series of concepts here
you have additional students for further
on in these concepts or filters out
beyond the current capabilities or is
this sort of like hey it works entirely
yeah it is difficult to say because this
was actually a work of a dissertation
and and I'm not just if there is a kind
of a of a chance of a finance chance
than I will further laughs interested in
continuing they don't and if not then I
can we can live with but it's also I
must say for this the elaboration is
thinking its legacy like a two door is
on it does not kind of harm if you have
if you think about such such problems
and go really deep then you get a
completely different view to this kind
of mainstream perception of of what is
state of the art program and then also
again that's a new input for also
designing usual sister likes in industry
because then you have somehow know what
is kind of the more profound conceptual
basis and what is a little bit like the
the provisional solution and should a
little bit avoided
all right thank you very much